plumes of Smoke Rise along the tarmac at
Khartoum airport on a third day of
fighting between Sudan's Army and the
biggest and most powerful paramilitary
force
explosions airstrikes and gunshots are
heard across the capital as both sides
claim they're making advances in
strategic areas but details on the
ground are unclear footage released by
the Sudanese military shows a number of
Rapid support forces troops surrendering
their weapons and equipment in Khartoum
the Army says it's resumed control of
State TV and will use it to update the
public It also says it's retaken marui
airport in the north but that conflicts
with claims by the rsf which says its
men still control the facility
thank God we're in control of the
airport God is great the rsf also says
an army-led Battalion handed over its
vehicles in the Eastern Nile part of
Khartoum State Sudan has been brought to
a standstill after attempts to open a
humanitarian Corridor failed fighting
destroyed khartoum's main water station
raising fears of widespread food and
water shortages only once to little
water bottle left this is a one and only
one and everything is empty now the
water bottle section looks so empty
all the water whole milk everything is
empty here on the refrigerator
and hospitals have become targets
shelling on a lab in this Clinic left
several people injured and forced many
to evacuate doctors say they're running
out of medical supplies a power struggle
between Army Chief Abdul fatah al-burhan
and his Deputy Muhammad hamdan daglab
commander of the rsf triggered the
outbreak of fighting on Saturday with
neither side willing to back down
on the political front diplomatic
efforts are underway to bring calm the
U.S and UK are calling for a ceasefire
the Arab League is pushing for
negotiation and all eyes are on Regional
leaders to bring the two sides to the
table the African intergovernmental body
egad is proposing to send the presidents
of Kenya South Sudan and Djibouti to
mediate the three presidents are highly
experienced president salvakir knows
both the Sudanese leaders very very well
and the constantly engages with them
president
um
is an elder Statesman of the region
highly experienced also in mediation
well respected within the region of the
region and president Ruto
while airstrikes continue and the
warring side show no desire for talks
it's the people of Sudan that are paying
the heaviest price rahila Muhammad Al
Jazeera
let's go live to Heber Morgan in cartoon
Hibbert what's the very latest
well after intense airstrikes by the
Sudanese Army against rsf positions
around the vicinity of the presidential
Palace and around the facility of the
general command of the army there seems
to be a reduced attention or reduced
amount of extracts being carried out and
it looks like it's more of a ground
battle at the moment around the vicinity
of the general command of the army now
the Army did say that this is where the
operations are focused in the central
part of hartum but we can also hear
reports of uh of fighting ongoing in the
northern part of the capital that's
across the Nile and in the southern
parts of the capital as well intense
fighting with people with both sides
trying to gain control of major
facilities the Army says it's still in
control of the airport but there's heavy
fighting going on around that area so
still it's not clear who has the upper
hand who controls most of the facilities
here but it's clear that they're
fighting even if it has reduced over the
past hour is still ongoing between the
army and the rapid support forces and
the Army claims to have retaken the
state broadcaster what can you tell us
about that
well we spoke to people who live in
underman around the vicinity of that
facility that the state television which
has been a a point of struggle between
the rapid support forces and the Army
now we know that the Army is in control
but we also know that know that there is
intense uh fighting happening around
that area and it looks like the rapid
support forces are trying to regain
control of the state television that's a
facility that they were in charge of or
in control of uh over the past uh 12
hours for 24 hours until just a few
hours ago when the Army announced that
they have taken over and that they will
be using that uh that station to pass
their messages on to the people around
the country so that's another facility
or institution that both sides uh that
the Army is trying to maintain control
over that the rsf is trying to regain
control of to try to minimize the
messages that the Army is sending out
all right Hibbett Morgan reporting from
Khartoum thank you very much and we want
to share with you this moment that took
place earlier in the day when fighting
was intensifying in Khartoum and one of
our Al Jazeera correspondents got a
little too close to the fighting
now what's clear from these clashes and
sounds
the shelling is very close we hope hate
them that you take care and shelter and
secure a safe location
Regional and Western Powers have called
for an immediate ceasefire and a
resumption of talks on civilian rule U.S
Secretary of State Anthony blinken has
been speaking with Saudi Arabia and the
United Arab Emirates they support
opposing sides in this conflict the U.N
security Council is due to discuss the
latest developments on Monday a regional
African Bloc known as egad also plans to
send heads of state including those of
Kenya and Djibouti to mediate as soon as
possible and the African Union chairman
wants to head to Sudan's capital
Khartoum to discuss an immediate
ceasefire as for neighboring countries
that include South Sudan and Egypt
they've also offered to mediate
now a video blogger who is traveling in
Sudan has shared his experience of
what's happening in cartoon
when I opened the window I could see the
black smoke around the air a lot of
people they are going by walking they
are going with their bags many of the
people they are loading the stuff from
Supermarket they are going in their car
and many of them they were hitchhiking
in another vehicles to escape the city
the general who heads the rapid support
forces Muhammad hamdan dagalo has urged
the International Community to take
action he posted on Twitter accusing
rival General Abdel fatal burhan of
committing Crimes by bombing civilians
from the air
the fighting threatens to worsen what
was already a dire humanitarian
situation in Sudan the U.N humanitarian
office says about 15.8 million people
roughly a third of the population will
need assistance this year there are 3.7
million internally displaced people who
need help around 4 million children
under 5 and pregnant women are acutely
malnourished and need life-saving
services and as many as 11.7 million
people do not have enough food to eat
is the spokesperson for the
international Committee of the Red Cross
we spoke to her earlier she says the
situation for civilians is only getting
worse
the most important and Urgent priority
right now is the access for healthcare
workers for ambulances for the First
Responders to be able to provide urgent
care for the wounded people so that the
toll the human toll of this tragedy does
not continue to rise for now what we can
say for certain is that we know that the
fighting is taking place very in very
close and in very dangerous proximity to
have a populated civilian areas to
civilian neighborhoods and essential
civilian infrastructure and we know from
experience in a in other places around
the world how devastating the
consequences for civilian population can
be so now people are hiding in their
homes and like if water supply system
hospitals if these essential
infrastructure they get damaged the
consequences for this Urban population
is going to be uh is going to be very hi
we are in touch with our with our
contacts we've been present in Sudan for
many years now and we've been in touch
with uh all kind of interlocutors so we
are activating all our contacts to try
to get the humanitarian space that we
need to be able to move around safely
and to be able to uh deliver urgent
supplies